on behalf of hexworks Welcome to the
Lords of the Fallen gameplay showcase
today we're taking a closer look at our
all-new dark fantasy action RPG arriving
this October on PC PS5 and Xbox series
xns
[Music]
spiritual successor to the original 2014
release it acts as a full reboot for the
franchise taking place in a vast
interconnected world over a thousand
years later
featuring colossal boss battles fast
challenging combat and deep immersive
storytelling players will journey across
two parallel Realms in this expansive
RPG experience the world of the living
Axiom and the world of the Dead
Umbro with each featuring its own unique
Pathways characters enemies and of
course Treasures
and while Axiom presents its own
challenges Untold Horrors await in its
nightmarish counterpart
thanks to the umbral lamp players can
enter this flightless world at any time
in one of two ways when slain by the
foes of Axiom at which point you'll
resurrect in the same location albeit in
umbral
or by performing The umbral Rift and
willingly sacrificing one of your two
lives
but the lamp holds yet more power
granting the ability to Flay the soul
from an enemy for some high damage
attacks and even manipulate the very
environment of the umbral world
however the longer you spend in this
wraith ridden plane the greater number
of spectral Terrors that will hunt you
down
but as harrowing as the hellions of
umbrellar they pale in comparison to the
game's brutal boss battles
towering above the ever-burning city of
kalrath this Garden can't you in
monstrosity doesn't take kindly to
would-be adventurers the Demonic
presence within ready to devour any and
all within sight
a merciless torturer prepared to carry
out any atrocity in the name of his
faith tancred master of castigations is
The Devout chaplain of the hallowed
Sentinels though beneath the pious
failed his very own flesh conceals a
truth most powerful
when Harrow or dervlon ventured into the
deepest depths of this world to thwart
the undead Rising what she discovered
was so utterly horrific that she
renounced her former life and commitment
to a far darker oath
pre-order Lords of the Fallen now and
prepare to unleash the darkness on
Friday the 13th of October
[Music]